nos dan esta ecuación de una línea y nos
piden que encontremos las intersecciones
y las usemos para graficar esta línea
aquí en la intersección se refiere a
cuando la línea pasa por los ejes x
y cuál es la intersección en x la
intersección en x cuando la línea toca
este eje va a ser cuando el valor de g
sea igual a 0 si aquí sustituimos el
valor de y con un 0 nos va a quedar
menos 5 x 4 x 0 va a ser cero igual a 20
ahora despejamos x dividiendo todo entre
menos 5 x es igual a menos 20 entre 5 va
a ser 4x es igual a menos 4 ya
encontramos la intersección en x menos 4
aquí va a estar ahora la intersección en
cuando se intersecta ye pues cuando x es
igual a 0 cuando tenemos esta parte así
que ahora en esta ecuación x lo vamos a
sustituir con un 0 y nos va a quedar 4 y
ya que menos 5 por 0 va a ser cero igual
a 20
ahora dividimos todo entre 4 para
despejar la sien y nos queda que 20
entre 4 es igual a 5 no es intersección
en ya es igual a 5 esta parte de aquí y
ahora sólo nos queda unir estos dos
puntos para poder tener la línea que nos
representa esta ecuación recuerden que
para dibujar una línea solo necesitamos
dos puntos así que vamos a tomar estos
dos puntos de aquí acá voy a extender
primero la línea aquí y ahora trataré de
hacer lo mismo pero hacia acá abajo para
que se vea toda la línea
ahí está más o menos esta es la línea
que me representa esta ecuación y use
las intersecciones en los ejes x y xi
para poder encontrar estos puntos y
hacer esta gráfica mis puntos usados
fueron la intersección en x que es este
punto menos 40 ya que la aie es 0 y mi
intersección en ya que fue 0,5 esos
fueron los puntos que utilice para hacer
esto